oh dude is so over the top lender man
blender people can separately look at
the possibilities you can do it blender
can blend spaces there so when you're
shooting something with the tiny gun
you'd expect the tiny bullet hole but
it's actually the complete other way
around you get a ridiculous huge head
explosion it's much more realistic that
way so I thought the best way to do that
would be to simulate skin flying around
slapping around i've alts flying out
skulls cracking to be realistic and true
to the source material the effects in
this video are pretty simple it's mostly
just muzzle flashes and bullet hits
which are very time-consuming and I've
had a few days to do these effects
why not go all out and just do fully 3d
simulated bullet hits for every shot so
basically for the shot how it started
was I made the rough shape of the torso
in blender and I manually tracked that
on to the shots then I took that model
and I applied a cloth material to it
it's a realistic rippling of the man
shirt then what I did to that was I
applied a cloth simulation it just
allows me plot the flap around and do
whatever physics wants it to do then for
the actual bullet hole underneath the
shirt I just small a little piece of the
check and then sculpted a hole into that
I applied a flesh texture to it you know
kind of painted on some blood gave a
skin texture as well just for the outer
rim modeled some bones which are really
horrible to be difficult to look but far
away
so with all that thrown together we have
a realistic blood squirt here's the shot
with the renders straight from blender
so we got to cut out the bullet holes on
each render have them not be 100% jank
we're going for 13 14 % jank with all
the assets cut up correctly this is what
the shot looks like
however since one of the bullet hits
should have gone under the actors arm I
had to cut out the arm place it back
over top of the asset then to top it off
we have blood splash smoke poof's and
then just general sweeteners to the shot
to get it ready for YouTube
okay we've got very special video that
we just released it's called tiny guns
and it's on the corridor Channel
we just released it so you should check
it out now it is ridiculous every single
time I get my hands on a camera and
shoot a video something weird happens
this segments called Nico's goose and
Gatineau you guys are setting up way too
much Sophie casual not like a group you
know so just because the bullet housing
he's got the silliest bit ever to be
seen on the Family Channel it's just a
classic thing here look over at Sam
don't move your face think about your
panel now here okay
all right now look at the closet problem
what oh did you just pan oh and separate
my eyes it's a little I could do a much
better one okay over time I'll be as
close but just tell me when
I know I know how to disable otherwise
you get the janky line in the middle
okay let's take a crack at it the first
thing I did as always is motion track
the shot then I took this random 3d pad
model that I got off of I believe
turbosquid comp I manually went through
and I meshed the movement of the model
to the movement of the actors head then
on top of that I broke apart this model
into multiple pieces and then it applied
a soft body simulation so that's kind of
just snapped apart and all the different
pieces of the head flew around and snaps
into the hood of the car projection in
the head I used this screen grab of I
use this screen grab of
the footage and then you know just
extended the skin to have realistic
colors for the skin this looks really
good that live render it is blender is
really good specifically with cycles for
seeing your rendered work as you do your
co-op cane can do that to all terms
what do you think it one wonders cool I
really dig the fact it has all these
like really nice features built into it
I'm pretty convinced that Autodesk is
trying to kill 3ds max yeah right it's
like okay how about we've already had a
physically based rendering
have like proper physics and proper soft
body physics and it's like well hold on
you're telling me that like all these
features I need are part of the program
and not like these janky add-ons that
are even third party or like poorly
supported if I were to tell you that
there's like little to no documentation
on 3ds Max's acidic system would you
believe me yeah can't find anything out
about it like there's nothing explaining
what anything does you meet some dang
physics applications that work properly
in aren't janky please I really wish
that Iran would have learned blender I
really wish that 3ds max had better
compositing tools like seriously it's
the year I'm using 3ds max 2018 and when
I take out a 3d render there still isn't
an automatic way to separate shadows and
everything from my image like I mean the
probably is actually I maybe maybe I'm
just getting worked up over nothing if
you guys know about something like like
a handy compositing layer kind of export
situation for the 3ds max or separates
your objects and your shadows and all
that stuff automatically
comment below flash subscribe
[Laughter]
so I'm supposed to tell you to go watch
a tiny guns while is doing that but it's
really difficult to talk and do this at
the same time
go watch tiny guns on corridor right now
you work in this for a while right here
is already and pistol tricks first take
first try go watch tiny guns on YouTube
that concept corridor nice lane one
right here - ready go watch tiny guns
alright
I'm doing you a too much mature Hill now
go check it out first link in the
description below
ok what I did next was I found this
skull model from TF 3 DM calm I painted
on some blood and then I parented that
to the face so now it follows the
movement and you can kind of see the see
the skull through the slapping skin and
discussing this after that I found a
model of a brain and I gave it a weird
fleshy material and I basically told
blender to interpret the material where
anything close to the centre of the
brain would be a bloody texture and
anything towards the outward shell of
the brain would be a fleshy slightly
transparent texture that's what makes it
look so gross then I parented that to
the head as well so it followed the
correct movement and then I at a certain
frame told the brain to start simulating
as a soft body so it would fall off the
head and squish onto the car hood for
the car hood I basically did a rough
small of the hood give it the same kind
of material so that the objects could
interact with it realistically and
bounce around and have the right
collision then because it wasn't gross
enough I found the model of an eyeball
online and kind of animated that
flipping around just hand animated the
eye is way bigger than it should be but
kind of hard to see without that so I
thought I might accentuate it a bit more
to put all that together we have
something that
looks like this which looks really
shitty we render it out get a final pass
of the head bring that back into After
Effects here's the original plate here
is a clean plate added on top so that
you know the rest of the head wouldn't
show up from the shot because it flew
off obviously we add in the head
explosion pretty gruesome but to top it
all off we throw in as many blood spurts
and smoke poof's as After Effects can
handle and there you go that's how you
do a really gruesome disgusting
unnecessary explosion for your time
against video yeah I know I know
I need like a tripod for my arm yeah and
[ __ ] dude
Jacques Watson Carmichael
how are you face week I am it's like old
man Carmichael here so you can stop
looking that way then I tell you to
you're going to look over that man
earlier and we'll begin and [ __ ]
here's a meandering shoulder-to-shoulder
all right ready wait look back no Matt
now don't you got it you need is a
little Dublin Brenda honey badger oh my
god you know I'm going to post that on
Instagram if you aren't calling us
Instagram at corridor digital on
Instagram there's a link in the
description below check it out those
cool pictures question yeah if you could
boil down our Instagram into single
sounds for each photo wasn't that like
video for another game surfer he's for
East Coast so I know it I'd to get your
[Music]